I did I did two pilots that never got
picked up one was a sitcom and one was
uh
one was I guess like kind of like a
Gray's Anatomy rip-off they didn't go
and I was Mr guest star there was a
there was a time where I was doing a
movie in New Orleans and there were
three guest stars Aaron at the same day
three different networks that I'd done
on like a Wednesday at 8pm and my mom
was like which one do I watch I was like
I don't know CBS ABC NBC I was on all
three
and it was one of these weird things
where I was doing a lot of guest stars
on a lot of commercials
and when Sons came
Sons is a strange story I auditioned for
every single rolling Sons like when I
say every role I started with Jax I went
down the the line and I didn't get
anything
and Wendy uh O'Brien who is the casting
out there just casts uh cast me in two
things one was a show medical
investigation with Neil McDonough that I
did like a guest spot on and she loved
and one was this Chris Carter movie that
never came out called Bellflower
um Chris Carter creator of the Xbox oh
yeah yeah she she was championing for me
on Sons but I didn't get it and I was
like and it was a weird time in my life
because my uncle Who was the the single
most biggest influence on me to this day
he moved to North uh Northern California
when he was 21 when his when my
grandfather died he left New York
and he became like a bit of like a biker
he was a rockabilly biker and then he
worked at San Quentin and then he got
caught dealing drugs and he went into
San Quentin as a prison like it was like
this whole crazy story and he was the
most colorful human being I'd ever met
in my life
and he would sit there while we would go
for walks when I was in New York and he
would just talk to me about these
motorcycle clubs
and he would give me like the history of
him and he this is years before
so I was under the impression that sons
was like my destiny because he died in
o4 when I was doing this movie and uh
Toronto I found out he died at the wrap
party so I was like oh
I'm supposed to do this show
but I didn't get it
and then about a week later I got a call
from Wendy O'Brien she said hey uh Kurt
the Creator wants to talk with you and I
was like okay she's like just just talk
to him he he has an idea for something I
was like okay and he's really short with
the way he talks and he goes uh listen I
don't know if you'll be in one episode
or a hundred I don't know if you'll have
one line or a hundred I I don't know I
just want you on the show and I was like
okay he's like but we don't have any
money and like it like but I just want
you on the show and I was like okay
so I went back and I was testing for
another pilot at the time and I told my
uh manager at the time
um they left me after this
um I said I'm gonna do that show and
they're like no you're not it's like
zero dollars you're testing I said no no
I'm gonna do that yet
and I did and uh I got made irregular in
the second season and uh my entire life
changed I met my wife through it my
whole life and my whole existence you
met your wife on set
no when I went over to Iraq and Kuwait
uh Baghdad like we did all the Uso tours
right
my wife uh she was a former news anchor
and she was um doing PR for military
Charities she started with Marcus
Luttrell on them and then she was doing
stuff for the boot campaign and we met
through that and um
a couple years later we kind of met you
know again and now we have two kids and
we live in a ranch in Texas so again it
all came from like everything else like
all my other jobs came from Sons and
came from that moment of like Wendy
taking a chance and Kurt taking a chance
and me taking a chance yeah how would
you sum it up like if you had to sum up
Sons of Anarchy for all those years you
did it I mean it was probably grueling
schedule and a lot of work right
absolute chaos but I have it no other
way it was
like Charlie and I just said when we did
that Reaper review thing with Kim and I
it was like going to college like for me
I had been around I was around these for
me again I'm like a
I love character actors I it's weird
because I would think all actors are
characters but whatever I love character
actors and I think it's like when I saw
Ron Perlman and Kim Coates and Tommy
Flanagan and Katie Seagal and like and
and I did the original pilot with Scott
Glenn like who I'd done who had done a
movie with prior to that I was
enthralled that was also a giant fan and
a shield so I was like so happy to be
there
um
chaos it was absolute chaos I when I did
Luke Cage right after it I had the same
executive producer writer who was on
that show with me and it was a also the
showrunner I had done this movie I did
lowriders he wrote that I was almost
like um
I Rescue all my dogs and so I know what
it's like I was like a dog who just got
rescued but they were like hey hey it's
okay it's okay they just need you on set
like it's okay because it was like I was
so tense all the time from Suns all the
time really just tense with wanting to
be great wanting it to work what was it
it was like a heavy show like it was
Heavy in all aspects it was
I could talk about the positives for
days like I don't know what it's like to
be in the Rolling Stones or the Beatles
or being like a rock band like even a a
minimal one
but like when we were together and we
were together all the time on our bikes
going to comic-cons going to restaurants
going to bars it was like being rock
stars like you would just roll up
11 deep and everyone was in the show and
people were like what the [ __ ] is
happening here